from Comedy billionaires Like Larry
David and Jerry Seinfeld yeah highest
paying job I ever had to guys like Louis
C.K buying a yacht with the money from a
single sold out show I can't I can't
afford this book these are some of the
craziest ways comedians spend their
money starting off with Dave Chappelle
who we all know has no problem walking
away from money but turns out he's not
afraid to spend the big bucks either
especially when it comes to cars
Chappelle's car collection boasts a
casual total price of 713 thousand
dollars and includes a half a million
dollar Rolls-Royce Phantom drophead
Coupe a 117 thousand dollar Porsche 911
Carrera and a modest 14 000 8th
generation Ford F-150
will you shut the [__] up Morgan Freeman
sorry but it's not just cars that gets
Dave Chappelle to open his wallet
earlier this year he started the process
of building his own comedy club in Ohio
called live from Yellow Springs which
reportedly has already cost over 1.9
million dollars looks like the comedy
Mothership might have some competition
soon I have quiet please money at best
I'd have to take a loan out for shut the
[__] up
with million dollar watches and custom
state-of-the-art tour buses still to
come in this video let's first take a
look at everyone's favorite Pig Tim
Dillon Tim is known for wearing his
flashy Louis Vuitton sunglasses on the
podcast which can range anywhere from
600 to 5 000 but on top of that his real
estate portfolio is no fake business Tim
owns a four million dollar home in
Austin a 2.5 million dollar estate in
the Hamptons and is even rumored to own
a third home a Sleek Hollywood mansion
in California so if you're looking if
these migrants are looking at houses off
season trying to make a deal I'm not mad
at them I'm not mad at them I'm
literally not mad at them now were you
looking at homes I got my eye on a few
up next is Tom segora because of you
nice folks I could I could buy a nice
house and I'm very thankful for that who
we all know likes to spend big when it
comes to his cars
I love modifying cars especially
performance cars I've done it to a
Porsche BMW that has a ridiculous
modification and this one now is
flirting with kind of crazy but what's
even crazier is Tom's impulse buys for
the people around him like when he got
his best friend Bert Kreischer a
historic twenty thousand dollar teacup
that used to belong to Adolf Hitler and
there is basically a 99
probability that you're holding
something that the Fjord drank from
at his vacation home
this is Hitler's cup that was Hitler's
cup yeah
put it to your lips put it to your lips
or who could forget when Tommy buns was
a guest on the ru garbage podcast where
he admitted to spending 50k on his
birthday dinner what would be the most
if if it sticks out that you ever spent
on a meal
I don't know if you want me to tell you
oh yeah we do I want you want to write
it down like a rich guy yes I'm I'm
gonna read it out loud
also how much cash do you have on you
right now
I don't know okay let me account
what the [__] let me say it
yeah give me how many people were there
it's just you
it was uh ladies and gentlemen
it was a group it was a group okay yeah
but I mean what city
Chicago can I say what the number is I
mean do you think we should we talked
honestly this is what people tuned in
for all right sure
52 000.
it was my birthday more than I made last
year on the books
no yeah that's your birthday of course
blow it the [__] out is that with tip
that was with tip all right with tip oh
yeah hey what's five percent of 52 000.
speaking of eating big meals Bert
Kreischer is no stranger to spending
money either when he's not at his newly
built home in La the machine is spending
time on his brand new tour bus that was
custom built to his exact specifications
potentially costing the comedian upwards
of seven figures I got a new tour bus
um are you excited I'll do this the best
it's the best it's the best it's the
best for someone who lives on a tour bus
like myself it's the [__] best did
you spec it out I built it yes yeah yeah
yeah yeah I built it it's who did you
use uh
with a net worth of almost half a
billion dollars Kevin Hart is in a
league of his own compared to some of
the other comedians we've talked about
so far an old school car can always get
better and it's something that you have
to nurture and take care of and I like
that I like the relationship between
myself and my cars and over the years
um that relationship has grown and grown
and grown and grown and Kevin's watch
collection is no different starting off
with his spectacular Rolex Daytona
rainbow which ran him 520 thousand
dollars but that's still nothing
compared to his ultra rare Nautilus ref
that's currently valued at a whopping
1.1 million bucks this this actually may
be my favorite watch is that steel this
actually this is plaid was one of 40. it
was interested in this one is the the
counter and the skeleton but I like that
like the black numbers on the skeleton
almost invisible yeah right like you
almost can't see it so you got to really
like get up on the watch to see it and
to understand it unlike the real Kevin
Hart Mark Norman has often been called
the cheapest man in comedy I love that
Mark's like yeah dude they don't tip and
the mark pretends to bust tables so we
can eat the buffalo wings
no one is cheaper that has never not
worked do it anybody can go eat scraps
off you don't have to you don't have to
pretend to be doing anything you can go
up and go here do you work here Mark may
be inclined to save money in his
day-to-day life but he still has some
spending power when it comes to the big
stuff so is it hard for you to make
these huge financial decisions for
something like that's so expensive like
producing a Netflix quality special or
was this just different than your
personal life you just gotta get it done
well that's a great question there fatty
but the real problem is I'm cool with
buying big I bought a brownstone in
Brooklyn I bought a BMW a vintage car
which was a huge uh money suck but I'm
not good at buying stuff for me like a
smoothie or uh new underwear that makes
sense but the special it's a big thing
so yeah I can Splurge I went all out
because I want I want it to be good you
know it's going to last forever you put
a lot of work into it so yeah I really
went I went swung for the fences on that
plenty of comedian his own expensive
cars or pricey watches but this next
comic used all the money he made from
just one show at Madison Square Garden
to splurge on a grand bank's 341 yacht
that's right Louis CK spent 250 thousand
dollars to become the captain of his
ship only to get it stuck in the mud
hours later with his daughters aboard
that was all of a sudden like wow
Louie's like a tabloid guys
in his
Beltway
stuck in the mud
uh this new black crows album yes it was
my first day in this stuck in the mood I
just bought it and I spent one day on it
with some guy who showed me the
specifics of the boat but it's this big
[__] boat with two engines
man does that sound messy speaking of
Messi the Rat King Theo Von keeps most
of his big purchases close to the vest
in fact vests are the only luxury item
Theo's been known to spend big on no go
back to the vest store in man so well
here's what happened so I you know I
would get I would do some cocaine a
thousand put on these different vests
how many did you buy again
I don't know I spent too much on him but
I would probably say
the priciest one I had was probably
about 210 nice damn yeah and so I would
get [__] up and put these vests on and
put on sunglasses and not let no like
Buffalo Bills [__] but at least partying
by myself
at joke world
and the world is wrld
that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out